fifty years after Israel's victory in
the six-day war the peace process with
the Palestinians remains stalled my
guest here in tel-aviv is Yair Lapid
he's head of the centrist yesh a tea
party and viewed by many as a possible
prime minister would he get them the
negotiations restarted or is it just
more of the same
[Music]
yeah alibied welcome to conflict zone
thank you you believe in your right to
live in the country with a Jewish
majority yes which you have you also
believe in equality which you don't have
in Israel are you going to bring that
about well I don't think we don't have
equality in this country family
reunification or instance I think Israel
is a Jewish state
I think part of being a Jewish state and
the Jewish democracy is making sure the
minorities will have their rights just
recently I think it was few years back
for example an Arabic Supreme Court
justice have sent the Prime Minister to
jail
this doesn't happen in the countries
within countries with no equality well
have have an Arab who's living say in
the West Bank or Gaza and he wants to
bring his family with him most of the
petitions will get turned out by the
court well first of all if somebody is
talking about Gaza we we are not in Gaza
let me remind you you control everything
that reason all right now we're not you
know we did first of all they have a
border with the Egyptians but let me one
we we unless on one border with us we
have done in Gaza whatever the word has
ever asked us to do we left we dismantle
the settlements there are me living
inside let me go outside me finish let
me finish and you know what to even left
him with three thousand greenhouses for
them to build an economy for themselves
and instead of doing so they have built
training camps for the Islamic Jihad and
fired until this moment more than 15,000
rockets on our children and you
blockaded him since 10000 M yes every
done even yes and we are protecting our
system are we not allowed to protect the
life of our children is this something
only the other side has the right to
let's go back to a family unification
all because because that is better wait
well there is a key difference it wasn't
a rhetorical question are we allowed to
protect the life of our children is this
what family reunification is about you
think by letting spouses of people who
are already very nice people they are
not arrested
in Gaza we left talking about my family
build an economy and country a life for
themselves I know you didn't command
family unification do you because it's a
big issue it's discriminatory isn't it
no it's not it's protecting the life of
our people what is happening is people
are using or misusing should I say all
the rights that have been given in order
to promote arrow so if you're allowing
them to do all sorts of moving movements
in Gaza ancient every time they've
misuse it I'll give you a better example
of their family and education I'll give
you a better example than family
notification we have let them so many
times to take out the sick and elderly
in ambulances and then we found all
kinds of explosives in these ambulances
because they are misusing every
opportunity there based on family
unification we have this from your
state's attorney's office that to bring
to achieve family unification is a
special benevolent act of the Israeli
authorities if somebody in one of your
settlements wants to bring a Jewish
relatives that is a right these people
have to rely the others non-jews have to
rely on a special benevolent act of the
Israel ahead that is not equality could
the lady and is it and they could have
had all the rights in the world if they
haven't used them to promote terror the
problem is I'm all more than willing to
give them all the humanitarian rights
they deserve if they only promise one
thing not to misuse them in order to
shoot and kill our people and they don't
so blaming the democracy on what the
terror organizations are doing is insane
mr. labayda fact is that Arabs for
decades have suffered one kind of
discrimination or another here in Israel
haven't you oh isn't that so since you
like facts so much let's let's look at
some after the First Intifada in 1987 a
judge led commissioned the or Commission
determined that the State of Israel did
not do enough or try hard enough to
create a quality for its Arab citizens
or to uproot discriminatory or unjust
phenomena that's that's a God
and set up its finish it's an
interesting quote because you say that
Israel hasn't done enough to promote the
rights of Arab in this country are
saying it in the Commission but still we
are the only country in the Middle East
they did anything to promote the rights
the democratic rights of the Arab
citizens because in the Arab countries
they have no right but you want so a few
who are so concerned with equality were
prepared to tolerate what this
Commission called serious distress
prevailing in the Arab sector in various
areas the distress included poverty
unemployment a shortage of land serious
problems in the education system and
substantially defective interest so what
you are saying what you think that the
country that is forming a committee try
to figure out what the right is the
right thing to do will be blamed for
doing so while those who do nothing will
never be blamed by you you will sit
there in all those Arab countries and
you will say you have to hold yourself
to a different standard that's by the
way from how does that's the difference
by the way how does billion Arabs feel
when you tell them right you just told
them right now that you hold them for a
lower standard that is this fair I just
told a billion Muslims that you hold
them for lower standards that you hold
us I don't think they will approve to
death with that I it doesn't matter what
questions I ask them and I asked them
the same tough questions I don't think
so oh you never see you've never seen
any of the interview you know I it's it
you keep telling that no you do that the
double standard is me is done by the
European media not by I don't stumps me
me with the with the you're feeling it
you have no idea of the kinds of
interviews I do with Arab politicians do
you have you seen any of I the way you
seem to I don't have to justify so
neither VI so do i do my country we are
doing at our best and the terrible
circumstances where people are keep
firing rockets with us do we have the
the bus terror we have people are
knifing our children in the street and
then when we form a committee trying to
improve improve the lives of the Arab
citizens of Israel you tell us you see
the committee said there is inequality
yes this is what why we're trying and I
go back to the question that I asked you
at the beginning what are you trying to
do to mitigate this inequality look the
latest Human Rights report from your
biggest ally the United States State
Department said oh criticized
institutional and societal
discrimination in Israel against Arab
citizens of Israel in particular in
access to equal education housing and
employment opportunities so nothing has
changed well world Commission report
does it yes I think here's the thing is
we're doing something about when I was
Minister of Finance I formed the first
committee of which said let's improve
the life of our Arab citizens we put we
gather that plan a five-year plan we put
a lot of money into it we did we took
steps this is what you do in a democracy
you're asking me if Israel is perfect
there's no perfect nation on earth
you're asking me if you're trying hard
as hard as we can maybe we can try
harder but we do try unlike others but
when you talk about reports about Israel
let me give you an example you tell me
what you think about it in the last
decade there were 61 resolution of the
Human Rights Council the United Nations
Romero's council about the ability
something everybody yeah we just stay
cause I'm angry can you just give me the
question yeah I am staying with the
question the question your wife's being
treated in an unfair way always say and
all the others and the answer is rayul
is the one who's being treated in an
unfair way I know you are you and your
life said this you said this many times
'king questions is unfair well asked
asking tough questions is unwell I just
asked you a tough question and you said
it's unfair it's a smear that night was
this media tough question the deal no
you you told me that the Western media
was biased that's all the time not a
question that was a statement oh boy the
things you say - yeah well and I'm
asking you questions when you're calling
Israel at this common toric country it's
a smear to me because we are not well
your government Commission called it and
and also the US State Department so I'm
just quoting them in in an interview in
February the Jerusalem Post you said
that Palestinians just go
around lying cheating and inciting and
drafting the radical left movements in
Europe in the u.s. to support them but
they don't have a monopoly on incitement
in this part of the world do they some
of your politicians have done their fair
share of inciting and then well you
should bring them over and ask them
about this I don't do I do not do
incitement I don't think it's the right
thing to do I don't think this is
responsible politics but if there's
somebody you have a claim to you should
ask him so there's a lot of incitement
here from all sides that well I don't
think there is any Israeli politician
who ever said that the Arabs have no
right to live and there are so many Arab
politicians around the globe and around
the Middle East that has talked about
the total destruction of Israel as their
aim and goal there is a difference yes
people are saying they're irresponsible
things in Israel as well
this happens in a free in a free and
open society but it's actually worse
than that because your president in 2014
Reuven Rivlin yeah said he despaired of
the hate speech in Israel on the
Internet
and he said of politicians and prominent
rabbis condoning anti-arab violence and
rhetoric yes I'm not asking he said if
we've forgotten how to be Jewish I'm
asking if we forgotten how to be human I
am so happy that not only that we have a
president who can who is capable of
saying giving such a speech but also
that we live in a society in which
choose a person like this to its prey to
become its Paris president I voted a
president I voted for him of course in
the in Knesset
because I think he's got a moral voice
in open societies you have all kinds of
voices what about well I think I think I
think criticism is part of living in a
free society reticular criticism yes and
I think there are many people in this
country who said racist things what you
want me to defend now every Israeli I
out there I'm fighting racism in this
country I fight fight I'm fighting
prejudice I'm in this country I did
things for the Arab citizens of this
country and I will fight for their right
for you can fulfill the equal rights
whenever I can and you want separation
this is your policy
separation to bring about the Jewish
majority do you want in Israel your
policy is to separate from from the
Palestinians I want a two-state solution
what if in the end large numbers don't
want to separate but then on the
Palestinian side because the latest
Palestinian polls show that support for
two-state solution is still below 50%
well what if large numbers don't want to
separate what are you going to do
forcible removal no anyway we'll be
talking about you're asking if we will
do anything that is unilateral I don't
think so I don't think it's the right
move I think you don't think so I think
that I'm going to do no we're not going
to do anything unilateral we tried that
in the disengagement as I said before
and it didn't work out that well because
a large number of Israelis would like to
see forcible removal there was a there
was a Pew survey done in March last year
nearly half of Jewish Israelis would be
happy to see forcible removal of Arabs
from the country well this is very
shocking evidence it is instability
isn't it well there is an austerity
peoples is deep and abiding people
people are scared people feel that we
tried everything let me remind you in
the years 2008 2008 in the year 2014
Israel formulism
to 14 2014 the government I was sitting
in agreed to start a separation of the
under the two-state solution in a
formula that that was more than 19 which
more than 90% of the territories will be
moved towards to the Palestinians to
build a Palestinian state and the
Palestinians refused so they like
standing in demonstration shouting free
Palestine and whenever they have a
chance to be freed they refused they
engaged in one peace process after
another with you this idea that there's
no partner for peace for Israel
it simply isn't backed up by the fact
well this I never said that what I'm
saying is you may not like the partner
but you have to work with what it is I
wish we had the taka being said that
before me I wish we had the conflict
with the Swedes then we can solve it
much pretty in a much easier fashion we
have we have a dispute with the
Palestinians when we have to separate
from the Palestinians and build the
highest ball possible between the 2p and
you will negotiate
a separation with them yeah but I will
negotiate it not the way they negotiated
it because you've already made your
conditions clear I mean you laid this
down you keep the major settlement
blocks that's your a unilateral decision
you said as it was said in the Boucheron
letter you you said in January last year
if I was Prime Minister tomorrow that's
a deal I would make building in the
blocks in Mali a dream erielle gush
etsion in exchange for a freeze outside
the block true but do you think the
world is going to buy this yes why why
because the settlements are still seen
they're illegal
well absurd to theory in the outside
world all of them they'll be there in
the block or a clearance one that is
considering the entire settlement so the
entire territories is the one thing and
one is saying there's a difference
things have happened this is the bush or
letter from 2001 saying there is a
difference between the big blocks and
between what is happening outside the
big blocks what is happening outside the
big blocks is probably the future state
of Palestine inside the big blocks is
Israel isn't going to stay Israel and
that's let's not pretend it's the same
and on the basis of your views you
taught a conference in January 2016 that
you could change opinion about Israel
abroad you said in the past six months
I've spent a considerable amount of time
campaigning for Israel's image abroad
I'm telling you it can be changed true
it can be improved we can make people in
countries change their minds and then
came resolution two three three four
calling your settlements in December
last year calling your settlements a
flagrant violation of international law
America abstain much to your horror and
so the resolution went through with not
a single vote against so much for
changing minds well first of all IIIi
don't think it's a big surprise that
will come as a big surprise to anyone to
say that the UN is biased against Israel
and whatever I was a fourteen other
countries who voted and by the way and
if you ask the United States today just
nikki Haley in the U and all the
American president abstaining and not
veto in two three three four was a
mistake now but there were fourteen
other countries yeah laughs II voted
are they all biased again no there's
wrong in Russia China is UK New Zealand
little Asia let me
mind you let me remind you behind the
palestinians is the entire oil money in
the world promoting their issue for 450
years now and saying that the jewish
state is all wrong and forgetting
conveniently that the jewish state has
offered the palestinians more than
ninety percent of the territory from the
sell you're getting outside no I'm not
I'm not getting off subject this is the
subject the subject is that you're not
changing minds if you get fourteen
countries including those like Russia
China UK New Zealand this exact France
this is going to changing them exactly
what I'm saying why I'm saying your
subtle issues like we should go this is
exactly why last up in September 2015 I
already put a plan saying let's go to
original conference let's talk with the
more moderate or more conservative Arab
Sunni states about the Palestinian issue
let's start a process doing nothing is
also a choice and it is usually a bad
one so doing nothing for me is not an
option what we have to be more proactive
I said that before I'm saying this here
again we have to be more proactive this
is part of changing the world you think
it's just a way of looking it no well
the one attitude may change if you
change your else's so now you're not
listening I just said we have to go into
a regional conference this is doing this
is not media this is not talking about
it this is not doing something but
you're not going to change your views on
the settlements are the big settlement
blocs no I am NOT this is part of Israel
and that's part of what the rest of the
world is not going to maybe so look at
the resolution has been telling us since
the day Israel was form you know what in
that even in the two thousand years
beforehand that it will be only nice
enough to the people around us
everything will be fine and then
terrible things have happened
I'm telling you Israel will protect its
interests no matter what and we are not
asking permission from anybody whether
or not to stay in our homeland what I'm
saying is we are willing to go to start
a process in order to compromise and
have a two-state solution but we're not
going to do anything that will harm
Israel's security
including leaving those major settlement
blocks despite the fact they are a major
barrier to Israel's relations with the
rest of the world well they might
imagine if there'll be a process and if
there will be progress it won't be a
major barek and you can repeat this as a
cuckoo clock but I'm telling you there
won't be any problem if we'll be in a
process because you know what even in
the Arab world they know now that there
is no way of going back to 1967 Oreo to
1948 we things have changed and this is
part of Israel is going to stay part of
Israel you have said that you are you've
implied that you are something new in
Israeli politics you told POLITICO in
March I think Israelis understand that
we need something new and clean and
different strongly suggesting that you
are that something love your critic
standing you're new at all former prime
minister what Barack says you know
different from all the other politicians
Lapidus said would represent more of the
same taking votes from the center left
but allowing himself with the right he's
right isn't it no see well you share a
lot of views of the right way and I
share a lot of views I share all views
that are practical and pragmatic like on
BDS for instance like I call divestment
and sanctions movement I am i I think I
have maybe started or was one of what
was one of the first ones to go out
there and fight BDS in the world because
I think BDS is a Hamas finance the
terror finance what's the evidence for
that well you know I will send you the
Wall Street Journal research on that on
this that proved that behind the BDS
movement stands Hamas money it was a
very good research you should read it
really so it's somebody else's research
but you you you have you can't tell you
can't give me away I will know we have
you can't give me any no we do we have
all the evidence in the world but if I
thought I thought to myself you know
being the journalist you are you don't
want the evidence coming from the
Israeli government of the Israeli
stablishment I will give you the
evidence of such a case from a
right-wing American because this has to
do with right or left or does this has
to do with facts so now even the Wall
Street Journal is not is
is not biased enough you describe the
leaders of the BDS movement as outright
anti-semites linked to the Palestinian
Mufti who collaborated with the Nazis
yes
you know these BDS leaders personal idea
oh come on no I mean this year you paint
with a broad brush no I don't paint
business what this is soaking headlights
these are people who are calling were
calling the Israelis killers while the
majority of killing of course is
happening not the majority the mass
majority of killing is of course
happening within is in their world
including Jewish choices for so is
always yeah well they know as I was
saying if you read onto the quote I was
talking about the fact this is based on
Hamas money this is based on terror
money and of course they use the regular
unusual is what they call how they call
it idiots that you can use this it's the
Lenin useful useful it is so you're
calling Jewish voices for peace in the
u.s. use for I'm calling everybody was
quoting the BDS movement either bias or
don't know what he's talking about like
the director of this movement
Rebecca Ville commerson who said I
wanted to take concrete action to bring
about freedom and full rights for
Palestinians so I embraced the boycott I
believe that Israel won't change its
policies until outside pressure becomes
impossible to let North OPDs
that's half of all ways to reduce okay I
don't know this lady but let's talk
about this view because I see the
minimis ratio this is a genuine feeling
yes because people now are all about
feelings and nobody's new you say she's
and I'm right auntie cos she's Jewish
man yeah and what I'm saying is now
people are only the only thing they can
talk about is their feelings they see a
picture in the newspaper on a website
and now their feeling is that probably
the Palestinians are right
no they're wrong what I'm telling you is
we have here people are standing
standing as shouting free Palestine free
the people who hang gay people from
telephone poles
free the people who think it's okay to
beat your wife free the people who think
it's okay to burn churches and the kill
Jews and Christians just because they're
Jews a Christian these are the kind of
people they want to free these
is the kind of people they want to
support this is the BDS movement that's
your view they think they're trying to
change policies and get equality well
you know what the Palestinians who live
under Israel so you know what I didn't
want to fake this is my view so this is
the way you know what so do your job
this is the way I look at this this is
the way they look at this why don't you
go out there and see what the facts are
the danger is though that Israel becomes
immune to criticism doesn't it bet sell
em your own human rights organizations
described as extremist by the government
they are extreme human rights ago human
rights watch who you refuse to allow
into the country in February until there
was a public outcry and what did they
get wrong hmm what did they get wrong
the thing don't you take criticism
anymore now we do take criticism you if
if you read that your failures and
restrict it yeah no we don't you know
what listen the fight against terror is
not happening only with people with guns
it is also happening on social networks
it's also happening in free media it
happens by people who use democracy
shamelessly in order to attack democracy
and you want to be like North Korea not
wearing any on you are staying here in
Israel you know we are nothing like
North Korea we have a we have here a
press that is freer than the majority of
countries in the world something you can
take every allegation to take it to the
extreme and ask me to protect myself
from the idea that Israel is like North
Korea is England like North Korea is the
united states like North Korea no and
Israel is not like North Korea and then
you tell you telling me I'm setting and
watching that and letting people I'm
asking a question and vetting people on
the basis of views they might have about
your car you have your various rifle
your via the only way to vet people I
have no problem with people saying
whatever they are you bet Humphries some
preset ones that the freedom of speech
doesn't give you the right to be taken
seriously so I think the problem these
organizations that you just quoted the
biggest problem within the Israel
site is nobody is taking them seriously
because unlike you we know them we know
the motives we know what they were they
are about all of them now is it Louie
you know these are very small fractional
organizations that are usually very part
of the Israeli radical left and they're
trying to promote a view that is not
very popular within the Israeli society
and as I was saying the only people who
support them are journalists to come
from abroad and don't know about much
about it
Gallup it could have your own conference
thank you thank you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]